le décryptage de ce soir sera consacré à
l'homophobie après les drames de lille
et de nice est une nouvelle agression
près d'armentières qui s'est produit
nouvel acte homophobe c'était ce week
end jenifer et 22 ans a été agressée
samedi dernier pour s'être affiché tout
simplement dans la rue avec sa petite
amie un climat qui reste donc difficile
certains accusent notamment les
opposants au mariage homosexuel d'en
être à l'origine en allant trop loin
ce qui ne les a pas empêché une nouvelle
fois de défilé ce week end alors que le
conseil constitutionnel vient de valider
la loi reportage à montigny le
bretonneux julie rocha soares elodie
moines
samedi une dizaine de voitures a paradé
dans saint quentin en yvelines à
l'intérieur des membres du collectif la
manif pour tous
toujours mobilisés contre l'union des
couples homosexuels
et ce alors que le conseil
constitutionnel vient de valider
totalement la loi et nous serons
présents partout et tout le temps que
notre combat continue nous rentrons
aujourd'hui en résistance l'opposant à
la loi se compare même aux résistants de
la seconde guerre mondiale lors de la
deuxième guerre mondiale s'est elle à
l'intégrité physique de la france
aujourd'hui c'est l'intégrité morale
donc je continue
un combat qui unit le collectif crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui soulignait
qu' on a l'impression d'être dans le
vent qui auront se disent on va dans le
sens de l'histoire
moi j'aimerais dansante envers mon avis
les gens rient rond et j'ai plutôt
l'impression qu'on est tombé sur la tête
et qu'on a plus beaucoup de bon sens et
moi ça me paraît hallucinant et lunaire
de devoir manifester pour dire une
famille c'est un papa une maman et des
enfants le cortège bruyant n'est pas
passé inaperçu à montigny voisins le
bretonneux et guyancourt où un mariage
était célébré mais tous les passants ne
partageait pas leur opinion
comme cette passante vois ça je me dis
que c'est un peu ridicule la loi n'a été
votée ce matin voilà c'est quelque chose
de la république il faut l'accepter un
moment il faut aller de l'avant enfin je
trouve ça ça va être un homme bien de
gueuler ta gueule parce qu'effectivement
il faudrait
un mot qui se taisent coiffant est passé
vraiment à autre chose pour les membres
de la manif pour tous pas question de
passer à autre chose
un grand rassemblement national est
toujours prévue le 26 mai à paris nous
parlons donc de l'homophobie à présent
sur ce plateau bonsoir germandrée dans
cette responsable de mont festi
association basée à villepreux et
bonsoir à sacha soir à vous et merci
d'avoir accepté de venir sur ce plateau
vous avez 22 ans vous êtes homosexuel
aujourd'hui vous avez coupé les ponts
avec votre famille vous allez livrer
votre témoignage dans quelques instants
j'aimerais tout d'abord votre réaction
quand on voit cette manifestation ce
cortège par exemple à montigny le
bretonneux les mobilisations qui se
poursuivent alors que la loi a été
promulguée par le président ça vous
choque
vous même vous étiez favorable à ce
mariage pour tous aussi au début nos
mais maintenant oui car on a le droit
d'avoir le droit pot commun comme tout
le monde on n'est pas à part de la
population
on est tous exactement pareil on a le
même amour pour une personne soit du
même sexe ou autres de toute façon va là
et ça vous fera que de voir si les
mobilisations qui se poursuivent
comment vont les interpréter c'est
ridicule et à ce que j'entends ceux qui
utilisent des enfants pour emmener à une
conclusion voilà l'enfant il doit être
ceci doit être cela non un enfant c'est
un être humain comme un autre il va
vivre sa vie et ça moi je ça me révulse
quand je vois ça et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment très désolant de voir
ça en france les gens montrait comment
vous réagissez vous quand vous voyez ces
images ce cortège encore sur montigny
par exemple où les mêmes la station
d'autres sont annoncés y en a réuni le
26 mai est ce qu'on peut parler de
cortège quand on voit dix voitures
enfin il y en a eu d'autres à travers à
travers la voirie mobilisation il ya une
mobilisation prévue le 26 mai encore non
mais c'est bien mais qui se menacent use
la loi est passée donc
moment donné qu'ils rentrent chez eux
ils ont fait le camping pour tous ils
ont fait tout un tas de choses
en tous les cas ce soir à 19 heures
place de la bastille vous pouvez venir
aux concerts pour tous mika en
l'occurrence animera la soirée
et là en l'occurrence ce sera la fête la
fête pour fêter le mariage pour tous
parce qu'effectivement on ne peut
qu'apprécier d'avoir l'égalité pour tout
le monde
maintenant effectivement c'est désolant
de voir des comportements comme ça c'est
désolant de voir que dans une république
quand une loi passe on continue à
alimenter donc et à cristalliser donc
les peurs attend on est dans les
yvelines
donc c'est sûr mais bon moi je me dis en
même temps il n'y a que 10 personnes ce
qui est désolant c'est que les actes
homophobes eux sont en vrai vous avez le
sentiment justement ces mobilisations
ont libéré un petit peu ouvert la boîte
de pandore libérer la parole autour
d'eux des questions d'homosexualité tout
simplement mis le doigt dans l'engrenage
de l'homophobie
le vrai problème c'est qu'effectivement
ça crée des vocations des gens qui ne
juste ne disait rien jusqu'à présent se
sont révélés et aujourd'hui on se rend
bien compte que une partie de la france
pas toute la france une partie de la
france est homophobe
on l'a toujours su on l'a toujours
défendu on nous a toujours dit mais non
les choses évoluent etc etc
non il ya vraiment des actes homophobes
qui sont perpétuées qui sont violents
qui sont pas simplement verbaux mais
aussi physique comme on a pu le voir
dans différentes agressions récemment
cessé c'est d'autant plus inquiétant que
ça se passe aussi bien dans les villes
que dans les campagnes et quel que soit
donc les homosexuels ou même les
lesbiennes il ya d'ailleurs plus de cas
de lesbiennes aujourd'hui qui sont
agressés comme ce que savons que nos
deux là notamment dans le nord de la
france mais c'est une femme de 22 ans
qui a été agressé pour tout simplement
s'être promené dans la rue avec la
compagnie